Are you familiar with Dr. Thomas Sigfried?
Yes.
What are your thoughts on him say that no tumor considered
five if you're in ketosis, no glucose, and glutamine?
Well, the only thing I don't like about his book he wrote
was at the metabolic, something of cancer
or something like that.
He doesn't practice.
He's just a researcher.
So he doesn't actually seek cancer patients.
It is book he only had an example of one cancer patient
who had smoldering multiple myeloma.
It's not a good example as having one decay study
to work through with your book.
And I am totally in agreement that many times,
especially if you have HIF1G defects,
and you're going to be way more prone for your cancer
to be feeding on the end stage of glycolysis,
just feeding off of lactic acid, because you don't convert
lactic acid into acetyl coenzyme, very quickly,
that going on a more ketogenic diet can be helpful.
So if nobody's read his book except the person
who asked the question, he thinks every cancer patient
should call it a ketogenic diet.
And to me, whenever anybody says a comment like that,
it's an instant red flag, because every human being
is different, every cancer is different.
I don't care if you and your twin brother
have colon cancer, it can be completely different
in your two bodies.
So it's just not, when you make blanket statements like that,
to me, it shows a little bit of ignorance in real life practice.
So I guess that's all I'd say about that.
I just disagree with that.
I think everybody is different.
Some people's bodies, their cancer speed
totally different than other people.
So I just don't necessarily agree with it.
I was too told through your genetic testing
that a keto diet would be good for me.
OK, so who's asking this question?
I don't remember your genetics.
You may have a lot of HIF1 gene defects.
So going on a ketogenic diet is something you could do.
And you don't have to go full ketogenic
and get into ketosis.
You could just do a modified ketogenic diet.
That's where intermittent fasting can
be super beneficial for people.
So I probably recommended intermittent fasting
for you as well.